Jimmy is in North Carolina hi Jimmy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
for taking the call Dave we've got a
question regarding our mortgage right
now we're on a 30-year fixed our
payments about $1,100 a month with a
4.5% interest fee and we're on the PMI
right now so we want to get it
refinanced I'm looking at either a 15
year at 3.125%
or a 10 year at two point nine nine
percent to ten year payments 1,800 and
the ten or fifteen is 1350 I know that
there's some kind of formula that I'm
missing on how quick closing costs and
prepaids we've gotten a quote on the
closing costs not the prepay yeah for
grant Oh for the closing cost is about
2900 okay and what's your loan balance
167 right now okay so every 1% that you
save is sixteen hundred and seventy
dollars a year and you're saving about
one and a half percent and so that's
gonna put you to about $2,500 a year
$2,400 a year in there okay in interest
savings regardless of what your payment
is okay so if you got a year if you got
if you got a three percent loan 2.99 and
you got a four and a half that's a one
and a half spread times your loan amount
it is gonna put you in about twenty four
hundred twenty five hundred dollars if
your closing cost is four thousand
dollars it takes you less than two years
to break even and everything after
that's gravy on the biscuit in savings
you understand sure okay and you'll have
a higher payment at a at a ten year than
you will a fifteen but if the interest
rate is the same the savings is exactly
the same regardless of the payment it
doesn't have you in the show but it's
yeah what's your real savings it's not
the principal reduction your real
savings just the interest savings
now the other savings on top of that is
the PMI what are you paying in PMI
yeah it's only 72 dollars a month which
is it ain't nothing but it's not as high
as it could be okay all right but that's
another 1,200 or another thousand
dollars a year off roughly yes not 950
bucks a year okay so that puts us at
2400 our 2500 plus 900 and so we're at
34 33 $3,400 and your closing costs
you're gonna break even in slightly over
a year by being rid of the PMI and by
being rid of this so I love the 10-year
plan that makes sense yes makes it
thrown on it hey I also I just want to
thank you over the last year we've
really dialed in and been listening to
you we've been able to pay off all our
debt get our six-month emergency fund
have a another beautiful baby and you
know be sitting pretty with the house so
your your podcast has gone a long way in
our lives well thank you man I'm proud
of you very well done very well done
sounds like you got your act together
things are happening in the right
direction very very cool